cinéma avec le dernier film de Robert
guedigian qui avait signé Marius et
Janette ou encore les comptes de l'Estac
comme elle l'accoutumé sa troupe
habituelle avec notamment Arian ascarid
qui avait été César de la meilleure
actrice mais cette fois-ci le cinéast
offre une chronique sombre de la société
d'aujourd'hui la ville est tranquille un
film sur la misère sociale Pascal
deschant Jean-Louis
Bousser le soleil brille sur Marseille
et comme dans Marius et Jeanette Robert
GED Guan filment les petites terrasses
et les parasoles à fleurs entouré de
toutes sa bande Arian les cheveux courts
Daroussin Dada pour les intimes et puis
Gérard meyan c'était lui Marius mais 5
ans après un compte qui fleurait bon les
soirées entre copains où l'on refait le
monde entre deux anisettes ce nouveau
film en est comme le pendant en négatif
parce que dig digian pour être juste
quand on fait une comédie il faut aussi
faire une tragédie ces héros se
débattent dans les difficultés comme on
dit pudiquement drogue chômage et
peut-être la pire de toutes la
désillusion politique tu imagines pas
deg est avec Hitler ben maintenant c'est
comme ça il boivent des coups t ensemble
tout ils sont d'accord ils sont d'accord
que au moins sur une chose c'est que
nous on est plus que le troupeau voà le
troupeau
ça ça me dégoûte
voilà jeis une colère contre ce qui
déshonore la politique aujourd'hui en
fait voilà il y a beaucoup de choses qui
déshonorent beaucoup de gens et beaucoup
de choses beaucoup de fait beaucoup de
choses qui qui déorent la politique et
je pense qu'il faut redonner de la
valeur à la politique ce moment jeis
dire que peut-être ce qui m'importe le
plus aujourd'hui c'est redonner
effectivement une valeur à la politique
au sens strict du terme c'est la
politique représent l'intérêt général
face à l'économique qui représente
jamais que des intérêts privés voilà je
préfère les pauvres gens qui votent
extrême droite au petit bourgeois de ton
espèce qui prétendent travailler pour
ces mêmes pauvres gens dans votre dans
votre bouche c'est dur je préfère humain
je une pauvre homme perdu je veux dire
effectivement complètement désorienté
qui n'a plus de boulot depuis 10 ans qui
sait plus quoi [__] avec ses enfants
et cetera et cetera et qui effectivement
dans un désorroit total va voter pour
national à beaucoup de gens qui
effectivement aujourd'hui pour se donner
bonne conscience imagine que leur seul
Annemie c'est le National il se tardent
d'être antifasciste alors que c'est des
N qui sont bien Bénard dans leur cou moi
le cinéma ça fait longtemps que je suis
plus
allé ton père le
cinéma puis de toute façon lui il aimit
que les films de bagarre et puis moi
j'aimais les films avec du sentiment
alors un film qui suscitera des émotions
diverses mais qui respire avant tout une
petite chose toute simple mais précieuse
un profond respect pour les gens dont on
nous raconte
l'histoire